so like okay here's here's my first
question to you guys what do you guys
look for in a content creator
if anything if anything because i'm the
type of guy people like whenever i get
asked
um like who my favorite youtubers are
like especially in conventions and
panels and everything everyone expects
me to
like say anime yeah my favorite attitude
yeah right
and like because it's my job like i i
try to make it like i try to watch
the least amount of anime content as i
can because i don't want to
i one like it's my job i can't view
anime content this in the same way
yeah ever again and two i don't want it
to affect my own content yeah
so many of them suck i'm scared i'm just
kidding
i'm just kidding no no but i i totally
agree like
you know it's like my viewing my youtube
viewing time
is my off time exactly i just maximize
with youtube man
every single moment of my life i'm
watching youtube so i don't i don't do
that do you watch any tubers though
like like a few like any tubers who like
you don't know personally like i
obviously watch your guys's content like
people i'm personally friends with but
i very rarely watch antitubers i don't
personally know there's some i like but
i feel like they're
not quite there yet like they're still
figuring out their style
so because they new or yeah because
they're new right right yeah
but i find enjoyment in watching the new
channels kind of like figure out their
own way
and like seeing their i mean my some of
my favorite channels on youtube are the
tiny ones where they haven't they've
only got like update videos
yeah i would name one or two but i'm
also worried that
i don't want to bully them i'm also
worried that they'll get like you know
ten thousand new viewers and they
won't know how to handle it yeah yeah
yeah but but you know you know the ones
what door you make
they're out there they're out there but
like okay i mean like like obvious
channels that we all
like and enjoy just like internet
historian everyone [ __ ] loves it
historian right yeah i mean like what
else what else come on the podcast
internet story yeah
um nikki jakey yeah one of my favorites
i remember naked i like cause i i
discovered him
he you know when you discover a creator
who's under
a hundred thousand subs you're like
you're gonna blow up yeah that was nakey
jakey for me because i discovered him
before
he even did his [ __ ] green screen
effects and he was just basically like
trying like a mix between donkey and
jontron yeah and
he was just like he didn't show his face
it was just pure voiceover but
he he was someone who i discovered
really early on and i could tell i could
tell immediately personality was shining
through yeah
he was shining through and he was going
to blow up eventually and then he did
like the first the first video where i
thought he was going to blow up was he
did a video about like
video game dogs which is like so
different from what
like other people were doing right but
it was just it was it just like it was
just so unique and i was like that's it
that's that's your niche you found it
i just i just love his like flow of
comedy like
yeah there are some videos where it's
like like one of my favorite videos to
this day
is the one where he talks about water
levels in gaming yeah yeah yeah and it's
such a short video it's like six minutes
long
but just it's just constant constant
jokes jokes joke shows yes with like
no room for error and i just love videos
like that where it's like
cut all the [ __ ] filler out just say
the punchline then immediately move on
like that's
that's the type of comedy i i i strive
to do yeah my thing as well like i
i feel like everyone knows like thinks
of him as just like the
guy who has a green screen that sits on
the ball but like as someone who's been
following him for ages he can do any
kind of content oh he'll still be
[ __ ] great
you do a lot of writing right so yeah i
assume you think his writing's also
pretty spot-on
i think his writing is [ __ ] brilliant
even i'm still trying to learn this too
to try and balance like
analytical like your thoughts and
analytics to
comedy yeah and like it's it's it's like
i've seen so many creators
and i feel like even my i might be one
of them who like some sometimes it's
like okay this part is analytical and
this part is comedy
but like to combine the two together
seamlessly is a [ __ ] difficult thing
to do
and to make it look natural as well as
really hard i think one thing i respect
the most out of nicki jake's writing and
like
nakey jackie's definitely not the only
one who does this but i think it's the
type of content creator that i
especially like and inspire to be
myself is that people who can who write
scripts like they're clearly scripts
but they write it and perform it in a
way that doesn't make it look like
they're reading off a script like
you know um nikki jake is obviously a
great example of that i mean
i think the whole reason why jontron as
well like exactly is because of that
right he's managed to like
as you said like mix the whole
analytical side with the joke side just
so seamlessly and uh
you know like if we're talking antitubes
as well like a demo
was a perfect example of that right like
i mean demo kind of just
kind of just like started his like a new
wave of like anime youtube content yeah
and
his style still prevails today in a lot
of people's content
right like i mean i certainly like look
up to that guy's
writing i think every i think pretty
much every big annie tuba does and
does in some way shape or form a weird
like not even like 10 of the way to
being as funny as that
it's like we're trying really hard but
we can't quite i mean
it's like how like because you can copy
someone's style
but you can never be that person right
because like
that's that's kind of like that's kind
of like the hard thing about being an
independent content creator is that
you can be influenced by someone but if
if you're influenced by them a bit too
much and everyone's going to be like ah
you were trying to be yeah you're just a
clone
yeah and like if you're trying to be x
person then in the viewer's mind all
they are going to see
is you trying to be x person right i
mean i mean it was that problem right of
back in the day when whenever
anyone tried to do any get let's play
yeah and it doesn't matter if you were
like
nowhere similar to him everyone was like
well this girl is just a pewdiepie clone
isn't it
you're just a markiplier and i'm just
like i got those comments like when i
first started doing course party people
were like oh you
this guy looks and sounds like pewdiepie
i'm like okay i get the sounds part
how the [ __ ] do i look like felix how do
you sound like feelings what the [ __ ]
i don't know apparently i mean i can do
felix impressions but like it's not like
i was trying to do them actively right
because
surprise felix wasn't the only let's
player that was around back then and who
i watched yeah
did you guys watch scott there was you
guys seen him i've seen a few of his
videos i've seen a few of his videos
i'm not subscribed [ __ ] love scott i
love you scott because he's like the
opposite of nikki jakey almost where
nikki jakey
tries on purpose to not feel like a
script where scott feels so incredibly
scripted
that it's it makes it almost funnier
right like i don't know he's just so
extremely consistent and he's been up he
uploads sometimes like twice a week and
it's always
such [ __ ] good quality right right so
good i
don't know i feel like uh because i was
one point as well jontron had not
uploaded for so long that they turned
jontron subreddit into scott the walls
are serious
because he didn't upload for so long
because everyone would say that scott
the walls was like jontron but more
consistent right
but it's still very different different
styles of humor and uh
i remember as well he he's like so anal
about like
keeping the same level of consistency
that he re-uploaded the whole video once
because
he accidentally didn't uh blur not blur
i didn't censor a swear word
in one of his opponents god damn man
that is commitment
he just seems like such a chill dude but
also hella awkward because there's clips
from conventions that he looks so
awkward
it's like the kind of energy that i'm
like man that's such a that's so honest
that he just yeah
just tell he like loves what he's doing
i mean that's just like a genuine like
youtube have you ever watched any of
these videos
i feel like i've definitely seen at
least a couple of his videos come up and
recommended but you
you might i definitely have might not be
for like everyone but
i think you definitely you can always
watch it and enjoy it but it might you
might not go away being like [ __ ]
love this guy but you'll definitely
enjoy it 100
yeah yeah he's really good it's he's
definitely on my list of people like if
every time he's on my recommended i'm
just like yeah
you know i'll i'll give you a go it also
makes me wonder
how specific of a subject about gaming
can you talk about like he's done
he did memory cards the other day he did
a whole like 30 minute video on memory
cards
and i was like i don't even know what he
talked about like i can't remember but i
enjoyed it but i remember thinking this
video is totally pointless about
oh then there's another channel that's
like that which i i really
i think you showed me this connor but uh
ahoy i was i was literally about like
when i mentioned i was like ahoy ahoy
yeah i was like i was like there's
another channel that
covers super niche and specifically for
the longest time
thought it was some like film studio
that hired like the sexiest narrator
ever yeah but i think it's legit the
narrative
yeah so to explain ahoy he does like
video video game documentaries or insane
really really niche like subjects i
think one of my favorite ones was
he went through like the entire history
of exploding barrels
and it's it's something it's it's one of
those subjects where you never
thought about it until someone like
until someone brought it up like
why is it that when you see a barrel in
a video game you just expect it to
explode right
it's just something that you've just
been conditioned to like to know
but then you you think about it and
you're like yeah what is the history
behind that
he's also he's also like i'm looking at
his channel now he's also like the
antithesis
of click bait like because you know what
his video on explosive barrels is called
barrels right explosive with a period at
the end i
also yeah genuinely don't think there's
only maybe one of the people i can think
that have like the same level of
production quality
oh yeah yeah the production quality this
man's videos are insane he's up with
we've mentioned before but like let me
know
like that's that's kind of like the
insane kind of production qualities
where you're like
this guy uploads one every three months
and i know why you upload one it's legit
like box levels of it
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] amazing video on
like what was the first video game ever
that's a
my favorite one was like where does the
history of like chickens
like healing you come from and like yeah
it's just great like
it's really weird like there are just
some youtubers i feel that can just take
these extremely niche topics and just
somehow able to turn it into a video
that you never thought you needed but
then the moment you watch it you're like
all right i kind of knew it yeah as i
was going
through my list i i did realize what
like really appealed to me and it was
like more so the human aspect yeah
personality because
uh do you know noclip by any chance no
they do video game documentaries that
are really really well produced about
like game development
and it's really really just insane
production great stuff but half the time
i
end up like just not really caring
because i feel like there's like no
uh like human aspect to it or a
personality yeah
it just feels like a documentary like ih
is great and it's amazing don't get me
wrong but yeah something like a hoy
where i feel so passionate from like one
person and some of the channels that
were mentioned today yeah i mean we've
talked about this before about like how
to be successful on youtube and i feel
like
having that human connection and having
having a personality even if you could
even if you are doing like a sort of
documentary thing inserting your
your own passion and your own
personality into it as much as possible
is the real like selling point of why
people will want to come back to you i
mean
i feel i feel like that's why um like i
i remember when
youtube went through this whole video
essay boom oh yeah and i
now i think it's like kind of it's it's
not starting to die down you know
especially on anatomy yeah yeah i
remember when like every frame of
painting
like came along and started doing video
essays and wrestling that was one of the
best [ __ ] channels
oh my god like nerd nerdwriter and
everything came along and like we had
this like video essay boom
and now people like they don't care so
much about
the the analytical side of things they
care more about the personality behind
it right no enemies they care about the
person telling the narrative
right because why should i listen to
like some random person's
uh like college thesis where there are
like actual experts on the platform now
which brings me to like my um my next
creator which
is a video essay channel because they
did a video essay
on uh was it shazam kazam what was that
what was that superhero movie
oh [ __ ] shazam yeah they were doing a
video essay on shazam it's
called pony smasher i've never heard of
the channel and he was he was doing a
video essay on shazam
but like breaking down how hard it is to
like the the little problems that need
to be solved
um when making a movie right and i was
just like oh it's just another video
essay and then
he starts using like um like a first
person perspective like yeah so
what what i had to do was i had to do
this i had to do that on this movie and
i was like
wait a minute this is this is the
director
of of shazam making a video essay on his
own movie
wow and i'm just like whoa [ __ ] that's
cool
yeah yeah it was it was it was the the
director of shazam
making a video essay on his own platform
and i remember
i remember like how he ends the video is
he says yeah
there was a point where i was just i was
just you know super obsessed with
youtube video essays
and then i started making movies and now
like he views video essays completely
different because
he he admitted himself as someone who
like has made movies like he doesn't
know
whether like you know you can break down
the movie's themes and
like all the back end of something with
the movie but like he was like yeah
sometimes it's just like a complete
accident
yeah you know you know what i mean it's
just happy little accident yeah
sometimes he's just like yeah was
yeah you know was did i did i mean to
like was there any meaning behind
making this curtain blue or something
like that and sometimes just yeah it's
just the only curtain that was [ __ ]
available
yeah you know and then like hearing it
from him after i saw that video i was
just like
yeah he's kind of got a point you know
when you've got actual [ __ ] directors
making video essays
on your own movie how can other people
kind of compete with that at that point
that's that's the point i want to get to
where like eventually if i ever make my
own anime or my own manga and i just
make a
a video essay on my own show
that'll be the ultimate flex yeah yeah
exactly so i know exactly why
they decided to use these themes because
i [ __ ] made them that's why
ambitious goals the most primary of
sources that you could ever get